We have a voicemail.
No good question.
In this voicemail, that number is two one
nine two.
David PPY voicemail caller says, hey, there's
a lot of crazy stuff going on.
But like, is any more money coming for Corona
virus because it's been four months and we
got twelve hundred bucks.
David, I was just really curious, especially
with the end of the month coming up, we've
only got one stimulus package, a direct payment
to the to the people.
Yep.
Wondering if you often knew what percentage
of the stimulus package, everything, including
going to the banks and all the cruise liners.
All these different companies.
Yeah.
What percentage of all of that went directly
to the people?
How much of our tax money was this style to
companies compared to how much did we get
our money.
Yeah.
So a couple of things there.
I mean, first of all, I believe that we had
a sick.
I thought it was six trillion total and that
two trillion was direct stimulus.
And then a bunch went to specific big industries
and then a bunch was available to smaller
and big.
Businesses through P.P..
I don't have those exact numbers.
And then the bigger question is this started
in mid-March for a lot of people.
We are now in June.
For some people.
This sort of started to ramp up in February
in places that took it really seriously earlier.
Is twelve hundred dollars going to be it or
is there going to be some more stimulus coming?
The second quarter numbers, second quarter
being April, May, June.
We're now in the third of three months of
the second quarter.
If we don't start seeing recovery, there has
to be more.
Something more is going to have to be done.
And I mean, you've got people like Rohana
with proposals.
You have other members of Congress with proposals.
Trump's not talking about it.
Is this just doesn't work?
Twelve hundred bucks and unemployment only
for people who completely lost their jobs.
It's just not going to cut it.
And one of the things we will be talking about
on the bonus show today is that a lot of the
eviction freezes are expiring.
Now, it's June 1st.
Some eviction freezes expire and people aren't
going to have money for the rent.
That's due today, June 1st.
So we'll talk about that on the bonus show.
We will also talk about much more, get instant
access to the bonus show by becoming a member
at join Pacman dot com.
It takes seconds.
And remember to get our free daily podcast,
the one hour podcast on iTunes, Stitcher,
Google Play or any of your favorite podcasting
apps.
We are there.
Grab that daily podcast.
We love it.